- I will say I can't
like distinguish between
the I'm eating pizza haze
and the I'm getting a little drunk haze.
(hip hop music)
I mean, I think pizza and booze
are one of the great
marriages of our time.
Jay-Z and Beyonce
are like pizza and alcohol.
- I don't know about having them together.
It's more efficient.
- It sounds pretty disgusting.
But I'm down to try it.
- It's either gonna be very good,
or disgusting.
(hip hop music)
- Ahhh!
(choking)
- It tastes fine.
- It just tastes like pizza.
We're gonna get drunk.
- Hmm.
- I taste it now.
And it tastes like
fairly (censored) pizza.
- I have no problem with
pizza, this pizza is good.
- If I get just a saucy
little lick right there
I'd probably really taste the booze.
- You said saucy little lick
and then did the weirdest
lick I've ever seen.
- It's like the first bite you're like,
oh, it's pizza.
And then you can taste
like this bitterness.
She's lovin' it. (laughs)
- Like a good Cabernet.
You just.
- Dunk your pizza.
- Dunk your pizza in it and eat it.
Like that's promising.
- This is how I'm drinking from now on.
I'm not tasting it at all.
- My standards are pretty
low, to be quite honest.
Like I do not have high standards with.
Did you hear me just mellow my words?
Dude, am I drunk?
- I like you individually,
and I like you individually,
and now that you've done
this, we can't undo this.
(laughs)
- It's so hot in here.
I'm sweating through this top.
Someone should take my phone.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna drunk text everybody.
- If you hadn't told me
there was alcohol in that
pizza, I would have eaten the whole slice
and not think I had consumed any alcohol.
- Wow.
- I'm gonna just drink this shot.
Bye-ee.
By-y-e.
(chokes)
- Oh my God.
- I think it can be a thing
since Jared didn't taste the alcohol
that there's also a lot of
other people that won't.
- If someone out there could
find a way to make this
not taste like vodka in it.
- That's one of my favorite
ways to consume alcohol.
- If you want to slow down, getting drunk,
you should eat a lot of
bread, this is good for that.
- They're both beautiful
in their own right.
- They don't need to be mixed.
- They don't need to go together.
- It's getting worse.
- It's getting better.
- No.